Earlier in our discussion of health information exchange,
we mentioned the Regenstrief Institute in Indiana.
The Institute also developed and it maintains
the LOINC code system for laboratory tests and clinical observations.
You will find references to LOINC in a number of fire resources.
Each code is a number with up to seven digits.
While the codes themselves are deceptively simple,
their names contain important details in their five or six components, as shown here.
These components or parts are separated by colons.
In this example, the first part,
the component or analyte,
a substance of interest is,
alpha-1 globulin, a protein that is a marker for inflammation.
We can see here in the optional six part that electrophoresis determine it's level.
Here in the fourth or specimen part,
we see that the test was performed on a blood serum or plasma sample.
Test results with a unit of measure of mass in the numerator,
and a volume like milligrams per decaliter in the denominator have mass concentration,
MCnc, as you see here in the fifth part.
Finally, Pt in the third part indicates that the measurement represents a point in time.